- Whatever you're thinking about it,
you will not get it until you take action.
Make that move.
I exist to show people what's possible.
I really do.
You need to change.
Everybody.
Everybody out there needs to change.
Life is, you can't predict
what you're supposed to do.
And I tell people, never kill yourself.
Never.
Because you don't know
what your future is.
- Hello Believe Nation.
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world,
so to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from actor Terry Crews
and my take on his top
ten rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
and when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(swooshing)
(grand music)
- When you're young and you a kid,
you have so many, I go
up in the hood, man.
Flint, Michigan, where I'm from
and they said Terry
Crews, you can do anything
you want to do.
You can do anything you want to do.
And then as soon as you go to class,
you tell them what you want to do
and then they, "Man, what make you think
"you going to do something like that, man.
"You crazy?"
And I say, "Okay, wait, which one is it?
"Now can I do it or can't I do it?"
- [Interviewer] Right, right.
- So I started to call people on that.
I started to call people on that.
I say, you know what,
I'm going to go for it.
I'm going to just try something
that I never done before.
I want to design furniture.
I want to be a part of this thing.
I said I'm going.
And you know what happened?
The stuff worked.
People started doing,
it started happening.
(applauding)
We took the furniture to Milan.
We went in front of all the best people
in the whole world and it got accepted
and people were saying how great it was
and how beautiful it was and I said, man,
don't never let anybody
talk you out of something
like that again.
- [Interviewer] Never, man.
- Never.
- [Interviewer] I'm a dreamer.
- Take action.
Whatever you want to do,
whatever you're thinking about it.
You will not get it until you take action.
Make that move.
Make it a small step.
If you want a house, go get a rug.
You know what I mean?
If you want a new car, go
get some car freshener.
Take action.
Make this thing happen for
you and it will happen.
Action, action, action.
You know, one thing that,
you know, I can really
attribute to every failure in my life,
whether it be personal,
financial, any kind of way,
business, whatever, it's because of a lack
of my attempt to take action.
I did not take action
and it kind of changed,
once I got the fact
that action is the key,
it changed my life in many, many ways.
This is where trainers mess people up.
I've had trainers who
totally just want to prove
that you could never do what they do.
And they have you paying.
- I know what you mean.
- Just to say like oh, this poor guy.
And they go to blast
you, like they want you,
unless you're in pain and you feel
like you're sick and you're throwing up,
they're like, yeah, that's a workout now.
Yeah, look at you, you
hurt, you can't walk, great.
And the whole point is, what I tell people
is treat the gym like a spa.
The first time you ever
go, just go in there
and walk around, touch the weights,
get a drink of water, walk
around and then leave.
And I mean, literally
do that for like a week,
two weeks until you just get to the habit
of getting in that door,
because what's going to happen
is eventually you're
going to start lifting
because you're there.
And you're going to do
something and then you stop.
Don't ever get to the
point where you're like
I can't feel my arms!
It doesn't work.
People want, they want my
body and all this stuff,
but I've been working out consistently
since I was 14 years old and I'm 44.
- 30 years.
- Of hardcore, two hour workouts.
30 years.
So it doesn't happen overnight.
You just have to enjoy the process.
Learn to enjoy it because
I'm sure there was a point
where you started to
enjoy losing 113 pounds.
- Yep, yep.
- And that's the only way
you're going to keep going.
I tell people all the time,
and I really believe this,
is I exist to show people what's possible.
I really do.
It's like go for it, try
it because another thing,
I am no different than
anyone else out there.
I am not here to say I have a super power
and it was all this.
It was just try it, go,
let's see what happens.
And all of a sudden when
you get rid of judgment,
now you can be creative, but any bit
of judgment kills creativity.
Any time you start to go
well, maybe I shouldn't,
and it's funny because
you look at a lip sync
or you look at any kind of
dancing or anything like that,
as soon as people see you being inhibited,
you're done, they're like
oh, this guy, what is this.
But all they want is for
you to give all you got.
- [Interviewer] Just put it out there.
- And then everybody's with you.
Let me tell you, Terry
Crews is going to give
you 150% no matter what.
That's my whole career.
How many times have you
ever heard the phrase,
you are perfect just as you are?
Have you heard that a lot?
You know what?
You are perfect just as you are.
You are so perfect just as you are.
Well, you know what?
You are not.
You are not perfect just as you are.
You are perfect, but you're not complete.
This is the thing.
And this is what I mean by this.
And a lot of people are going
to go, aw, what do you mean?
What are you trying to say?
I got to change?
I got to change somebody else?
Yes, yes.
You need to change.
Everybody.
Everybody out there needs to change.
We are designed for change.
Nothing in this world stays the same.
You are either getting better
or you are getting worse.
Let me describe something to you.
When I say you are perfect,
but you are not complete,
let's say this building I'm in.
If I looked at the
blueprints for this building,
the blueprints for this building before
it was built were perfect.
Everything was in its right place.
Everything was great,
but could I walk in it?
Could I do anything?
Did I have a building?
No.
Why?
It wasn't complete.
When they framed up this
building and put wood
and metal and all this
stuff, but they didn't
do the floor or the
electrical, was it perfect?
Yes, it was perfect,
but it wasn't complete.
You are like this building.
You are perfect in every way,
but you're just not done.
You're not done and you know what?
Anybody who's trying
to tell you, don't try
to change me.
Now, no one should try to
change you, but you have
to change yourself.
You owe it to everyone to change yourself
into a better person,
into a better human being.
That's what you have to do.
You are perfect, but
you're just not complete.
So, when you look at yourself,
look at yourself like that building
and it's framed up and everything
is in its right place,
but you just not done.
I want to tell you that.
So, anybody who's trying to tell you
that I'm perfect just the way I am
is not trying to change and guess what?
You're not and it's not working.
You're a half done building.
Who wants to live in a
building with no roof?
Nobody and I'm just trying
to break it down to you
that you hear these catchphrases.
You hear this stuff all the time,
but then everybody just takes it and says,
oh, yeah, I'm perfect just the way I am.
And you don't change and
your life doesn't change
and nothing gets better for you
and you wonder what's
happening and everything
is crumbling around you.
Hey, I'm guilty.
Terry Crews is guilty, then I realize,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
I'm not perfect just the way I am.
I have to be perfected.
I am perfect, but I am not complete.
The thing about self-discipline
is that it is necessary
for everything you do in your life.
You have to be self-disciplined.
If discipline comes from somewhere else,
it's very, very hard to remain consistent
because you tend to resist.
It's wild because I see
trainers and they're
in the gym with people
and, you know, the guy
or girl that they're working
out hates their workout,
hates it, because the discipline is coming
from somewhere else.
It's something that you
dread every time you go in,
you don't really want to do it,
it's like unh, but oh,
no, my trainer's here,
he's about to beat me up
and make me feel crazy.
Well, the truth is every
trainer should work his way
out of your life.
Anybody who's working
you out, your teachers,
your trainers, your people,
they have to train you
to get out of your life,
so you can go ahead,
do your own workout, do your own thing,
practice self-discipline.
Now one thing I want to
straighten out big time,
discipline is not punishment, it's not.
Discipline is training.
That's all it is.
I was talking to my son
one time and I asked him,
it was weird because I
was trying to see if he
really knew what it was
all about and I said,
"Hey, man, you know I
have to discipline you.
"What is discipline?"
He goes, "Punishment,
punishment, when I do
"something wrong and you punish me."
I was like, "No, no."
Discipline is training.
If you change your mind,
your mindset and really
focus it on what discipline really is,
you start to welcome discipline.
You welcome self-discipline
into your life.
If you talk to me and I was into football
and I was a football player
and you would have told me
I would be doing what I was
doing, I would have said no,
you're crazy, leave me
alone, get out of here.
This is why life is, you can't predict
what you're supposed to do.
And I tell people, never
kill yourself, never.
Because you don't know
what your future is.
You just don't and that's the
thing is, it's like for me,
I never would have thought
I would be doing this,
but I decided to try things.
I just decided that I didn't have to do
what everyone else said I needed to do.
It's like, you know, when
you're a football player,
everyone tells you this
would be the best route
to do after you're done.
Well, I decided to go another way.
And people thought I would fail.
I remember when I moved
to LA and everybody said
what are you doing?
You're an old football player.
You know what, they don't care.
And it was hard.
I was actually doing
security for a little while
and, you know, we went
broke for a little while,
but it was an amazing
thing, though, is that
as I kept trying new things,
new doors kept opening
and I never thought I would be an actor,
but here I am, I'm acting.
I've been acting for 15 years.
You never know what's going to happen.
You never know what the
future holds for you
and it may be acting, it may be business,
it may be performing,
it may be homemaking,
but whatever it is,
you have to explore it.
You have to go for it.
One thing I did is I wrote down my goals.
I wrote my top ten things
I wanted to do in life
and if it fit in there, I would do it,
even if it was for free,
even if it was for free
because the thing is if it fits my goals,
then it's going to work out somehow.
- Exactly.
- You know what I'm saying?
I've done a lot of things for free.
And they always came and paid me later,
now if you use money
as the only way to go,
you going to miss the right thing.
You going to miss the
right thing you need to do.
So that's my whole
mentality is just to go out
all the time.
I got one speed.
I'm all in or I'm asleep.
You know there's no such
thing as overnight success
because it took a long, long time, I mean,
I've been acting for about
11 years, but to look
at from when I started to
looking at the billboard
in Times Square and seeing
The Expendables sitting there,
that's tremendously fast,
you know what I mean?
And I've never been in
a hurry because I enjoy
doing this so much.
I just enjoy being around
guys like Stallone,
you know, Mickey Rourke, Randy Coutour,
just learning how to be a better actor,
how to be a better person.
These guys have done major, major things
in athletics, in life in all kind of ways.
It kind of took a sports
mentality to my acting
and that focus.
It's not about the parties,
it's about the performance,
you know what I mean?
My goal was if I was going
to be funny, go all out,
like go to a point where
they're like wait a minute,
I can't even air that.
You got to get rid of
those haters in your mind.
- Right, it's all in your mind.
- It's totally it and then
the judgments that you hear
and you accept, you start
putting that on other people.
- Totally.
- So true.
- When a hater tells you
oh, man, you can't do that,
that's because he's
hearing that in his head.
- Yep.
- You know what I mean?
Or you can't lose all that weight.
That's because he hasn't lost weight.
- And he doesn't want to.
He's afraid of the work that it will take
for him to do it, totally.
- It's all fear, it's
all, it's a wild, wild mix
and I just when I'm talking about that,
it's like in your own brain.
There are times when I
do something so idiotic
in front of a group of
people just so I can get
used to getting away from.
- The norm.
- Like fitting in or whatever.
I do some stupid stuff.
I'll just say something
dumb, deflect the chicken
and it's like who cares, who cares.
If I wear something dumb, who cares?
If I walk around with a wig on, who cares?
You can't judge me.
I have no shame, it's not going to happen.
And that is where I started
to go like now I can go
and be free.
- Because there's
nothing holding you back.
- There's nothing holding me back.
- What'd you do in high school.
- Listen, I went from
football to basketball
to track to break dancing,
that's what I did.
I was, I mean, it was the
middle of the break dance
phenomenon and I practiced like a fool.
- Did you have a crew?
- Oh, yeah, I had a crew, it was all good.
We were called the Big Man Breakers.
(laughing)
Real original.
- The Big Man Breakers.
- We were real original.
We were all pretty big.
- What years was this?
- Oh, this was 86, 84, I
mean this is at the height.
- [Jimmy] Electric Boogaloo.
- Electric Boogaloo was
out, you know what I mean.
- [Jimmy] Beat Street.
- Beat Street, it was hot.
Yeah, it was hot.
- Really and did you
just throw cardboard down
and lay it down.
- We had cardboard in the basement, man,
and I would practice spinning
on my head for hours.
I mean, no girlfriends,
nobody would even get near us
because they're like they're spinning,
could they stop spinning.
You know, we want to listen
to some Prince right now.
Can you please stop spinning.
- Did you have a go to move?
- I had the go to move,
which was the robot.
I have the best robot of all time.
Play something.
(funky music)
(laughing)
- That's how you do it.
(cheering)
that was a great one.
- As I get older, the
moves get more subtle,
because you're like I'm hurting.
But you see, just a
little, little touches,
that's all you got to do.
- You're just so much
energy and so positive.
How do you stay so positive?
- You know what, the key to energy,
I get that asked a lot, they ask me a lot,
but the key to energy is gratitude.
It's truly, truly gratitude.
(cheering)
it's real.
The more thankful you are,
the more energy you get.
Have you ever, I've been
where I was ungrateful
and you literally feel the
energy being sapped from you,
you know what I mean?
But once you find one
thing to be grateful for,
all of a sudden you get
the energy to do things.
I'm from Flint, Michigan.
I am a statistic that
didn't go by the statistics.
Because a lot of my friends are in jail,
a lot of my friends have died.
A lot of my friends are no longer here
and I look, here I am, in
front of the whole world,
all the time, doing what I love,
which is amazing.
You just feel the energy.
I feel happy, I feel joy
and that's for you, too.
Anybody in the world can find that.
(cheering)
(funky music)
- I love this guy, come on.
Terry Crews.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Saketh asked me to,
so if there's someone
you'd like me to cover
in the next top ten check out the link in
the description so you
can go and cast your vote.
I also want to give you a quick
shout out to Jane Cassell.
Jane thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word, and
posting that picture online.
I really appreciate it and I hope
you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love,
I'll see you soon.
(swooshing)
- People have heard
the term purpose a lot.
They always say, you know,
you've heard the term purpose
driven life and what's
my purpose and you know,
I have to be purposeful.
And the truth is, you know, you do.
But a lot of people get confused about
what that really, really means.
When people think about purpose,
they think, you know, what's
the purpose of my life.
My purpose is to be a good person.
It's to be a good person.
And I understand it and you're right.
You are not wrong about your purpose
in being a good person.
But you are not focused enough.
Let me tell you something.
When I was young, the whole
thing about being purposeful
or having a purpose, it's
one of those things where
if you don't know exactly
what you do on your job,
you know, I had a job one time,
it was really hilarious, I actually worked
at a liquor store and I was in college
and I remember just not really knowing
why I was there.
(laughing)
It was just about getting
my money, you know,
my purpose was to restock some things
and kind of do some stuff and I remember
actually applying for another
job in the middle of it
and I told my boss like, yeah, you know,
I went for another job,
but I'm just going to
be here until that other job calls.
You know she fired me on the spot
and I was shocked.
I was like, man, why can't
this woman understand
that I need some more money.
But what I didn't
understand was my purpose
for being there.
My purpose for being
there was to help her.
Not be there until I get another job
and keep my mind all on other things
because my job was to carry
those big crates of soda,
to restock the cabinet, restock whatever
I needed to do and really, you know,
do the cash register, do
whatever I needed to do,
but my purpose was messed up, it was whack
and that's why I got fired.
Purpose is really about finding out
what it is you do.
What is your role.
A lot of people get this mixed up,
because let me tell you something.
You don't get paid for what you know,
you get paid for what you do.
That's what you get paid for, that's all.
People will tell me, oh, I know all that,
I know this and I know
that, but what you know
doesn't get you your money.
Only what you do and to know exactly
what to do you have to know your purpose.
If you don't know your purpose,
you are probably confused
and you'll be out
and if you don't do what
you're supposed to do,
the world is going to miss
what you're supposed to bring.
They're going to miss what you have.
You must find your purpose.
You must find what it is
you were always, always
meant to do.
That is the biggest fight
ever and once you find it,
it's the key to your success, it's the key
to you being who you're supposed to be.
I am the best over actor ever.
Like if you give me
something and you tell me
to do it big, I do it really big,
but I love that because
it's kind of my personality.
I'm a very big personality.
I like doing thing loud,
I like being explosive
and I like attention, so
it all works together.
You're going to mess up.
You're going to see something
that you didn't mean to see,
you're going to eat something
you didn't mean to eat,
you're going to overdo
it, you're going to binge,
you're going to mess up.
You're going to fail.
You are.
Remember what that feels like, remember.
Because failure really is only temporary
if you don't take it as a loss.
If you take is as a learning opportunity,
it's only temporary, but
it can only be permanent
if you say you lose and you give up.
That's the only way
things can be permanent.
Forgive yourself and move on.
Move on.
Practice forgetting any of the other junk
that you did, a mistake you did.
Let me tell you.
The day is short and let me tell you,
it's not a thing that you
even have to remember,
just go on and keep
continuing on the right path.
When you mess up, start over.
Start over right away and
I'm trying to tell you
you do that enough, you
eventually don't mess up.
You eventually, it's kind of like a child
who falls down every
time he gets up to walk.
Well, you know, he will fall down.
That's just the nature of the beast.
But let me tell you as time goes on,
he learns not to fall and you will too.
You will too, but imagine
if you were a kid,
if you fell down once
and you just laid there
and you laid there forever.
Well, guess what, it doesn't work.
That is the same way you work.
That's the same way even adults do.
Sometimes we fall down, you miss the mark
and you just stay down there,
but you can do it.